yo what is up everybody it is prestigio
man Luigi here with another Borderlands
the pre-sequel legendary guy today I'm
gonna be showing you guys the cryo
phobia this might sound familiar because
it is similar to a Borderlands 2
legendary which is the pyro phobia so
this is a legendary molly wan rocket
launcher as you can see from the screen
it's red text reads no argument here
it deals bonus elemental damage and it
is always a cryo based weapon because it
is the cry of phobia like the pyro
phobia was always a fire weapon the cryo
fog it always is cryo the bonus
elemental damage might be from my prefix
the person however I'm not sure about
that so you can see here I've 1151 it
does some pretty good damage for Hunt
43,000 damage 826 has good accuracy and
then slow fire rates because it's a rock
launch of a 5 second reload time which
is that is it's pretty pretty slow it
has good size it's alright magazine size
adding some good freezing it is a pretty
good rocket launcher in my opinion it
does when you shoot it in I'd say the
reason it's qualifies itself as a
legendary is when you shoot it in shoots
imagine like a slow moving laser that
pulses out explosions every few meters
you'll see more at the end of the video
I have some gameplay me killing guys
with it so that you get to see that for
yourself how you like it I think it is a
pretty good rocket launcher it is pretty
good for getting yourself up when you
get down however it's slow slow slow
reload so if you're at the bottom of the
clip that's not gonna be working out I'm
gonna be showing you guys how to get it
and then as I said a little bit of
gameplay of it so I hope you enjoy
alright the first thing you're gonna
want to do is you're gonna wanna head to
pity's fall since we're gonna be taking
out the boats in the bosun is a guy from
the main campaign so you should remember
him he's a military AI tech guy who's
floats on a chair you can see on the map
where in pity's fall we're gonna make a
big u-turn and this large corridor here
is where ever you're going to be
fighting the bosun I'm gonna
speed up the gameplay a little bit it's
really just running past all the guys
that's gonna be the best way to get to
him fast it might seem like a long haul
duh since every time you're gonna want
to farm him you're gonna have to go
through this run again but it's not too
bad you're just gonna run straight
through your net to get that door to
open just run straight up to the door
and then you get down make sure you have
one of the guys around there low enough
so that you can kill them pretty quickly
to get up again you can ignore most of
the enemies if you get down you gotta
feel a guide but chances are you won't
get down I usually don't even though I
did that first time so here's the bow
scent and if you got the shield
generators shields flying around now if
you're if you have pretty good burst
damage which I do as Nisha then you can
ignore the shield regenerators and just
go straight for the bosun you'll be able
to kill him faster than the shields can
regenerate and he won't be too much of a
problem however when you do kill him his
loot lies everywhere so you're gonna
want to make sure that you walk around
and make sure that he the gun didn't
drop and you missed it since if it drops
and you miss it then that's gonna suck
so make sure you look around everywhere
for it so as I said here's the gameplay
you can see a little bit when I get
farther shots it does it's kind of like
a slow moving laser as I said and it
pulses out pieces of cryo it is a really
cool effect in my opinion and if it does
it directly hit a guy then it is it it
is going to stop pulsing it doesn't go
on forever also you might have noticed
these Splash Damage if you shoot the
ground next to a guy really isn't good
so you're gonna have to aim for that
straight hit or forward to get one of
the pulses to get them it is pretty slow
moving but it is a rocket launcher so it
should be expected and you can see here
some more of the pulses and stuff so
that's gonna be about it I do think it's
pretty good rocket launcher it's one of
the semi few amounts of normal farm
mobile Legendary's so I think that is
one good reason to get it since it is
something to do because there isn't a
whole lot of like game in for
the pre-sequel so that's about it for
the video
I hope you guys have enjoyed this make
sure you check out my other legendary
guides if you're more into that I'm
going to be continued posting them I
hope to aim
I hate hope to get a video up of every
single legendary in the game and so yeah
I keep looking at my channel for that
stuff hope guys enjoy it and see you
later
peace out